hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar how
community hospital labs
can perform comprehensive genomic
profiling with the support
of professional clinical interpretation
services
i'm alexis krause of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots
and sponsored by kyogen to learn more
about our sponsor
please visit their website at kyogen.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
cheryl elkin
chief scientific officer kaiogen digital
insights
and dr linda kaul director of scientific
and clinical operations at kyogen
digital insights
dr elkin welcome you may now begin
your presentation
thank you very much for the kind
introduction
the era of precision medicine has led to
a revolution in cancer treatment
historically cancer was treated based on
the organ of origin
and treatment protocols often varied
widely depending on the institution
where the patient was treated
however cancers that originate in the
same organ can be driven by different
genetic alterations
the advent of molecular diagnostics and
targeted therapy changed the landscape
of cancer treatment
suggesting that cancers that originate
in the same organ
could be treated effectively with
different therapies based on their
particular molecular profile
similarly cancers that originate in
different organs can share genetic
drivers
so cancers in different organs with the
same drivers may be most effectively
treated using the same targeted
molecular therapy
these observations led to the
development of increasingly complex
molecular tests that identify the
molecular changes in the tumor
allowing a physician to target that
tumor with a specific therapy
over the last 20 years the number of
identified cancer drivers
as well as the targeted therapies
available to address those molecular
drivers
has increased exponentially as a result
the molecular diagnostic testing has
also grown
from individual gene sequencing to
large-scale
next generation sequencing known as ngs
examining panels of genes from 50 to
hundreds or even thousands of genes
the adoption of larger and larger
comprehensive panels
has led to an increase in the amount of
data requiring interpretation
the larger the panel the larger the
number of novel variants that will be
uncovered in each test
ngs testing is being expanded beyond
small panels for specific cancers
to larger pan cancer panels to discus
to cover disease agnostic approved drugs
as well as off-label and investigational
drugs
all of these drivers are leading to a
projected increase in the cost of
interpretation
as a proportion of the test cost in 2018
the cost of interpretation represented
approximately 33 percent of the cost of
the test
however by 2026 it is projected to
represent
56 percent of the cost of a test
inter interpretation is a complex
endeavor as
customers use many different panels and
chemistries
the comprehensive cancer panels are
becoming more and more ubiquitous across
the market
as they can be used for any cancer type
and can detect
many different types of alterations snvs
indels cnbs and structural variants
as well as msi these panels have also
have also also have sufficient
sequencing coverage
to calculate tumor mutational burden
these large
panels are being utilized across cancer
types
for both solid tumors and hematological
malignancies
and the interpretation burden is
significant as the number of variants
that emerge from these panels
is significantly greater than the number
of variants from a small targeted panel
and while there are some markers whose
interpretation is applicable across
tumor types
other biomarkers require disease
specific interpretation
to highlight evidence that is specific
to a variant within a specific disease
the comprehensive cancer panels present
unique challenges to the laboratories
who must filter and annotate the
variants detected and to the physicians
who receive the reports
with such large numbers of variants a
lab director or pathologist must
prioritize and distinguish
clinically relevant variants from
passengers and variants of unknown
significance
in order to make some of these
assessments the lab requires access to
current
information on clinical guidelines drug
approvals and ongoing studies
in a field where the body of literature
is expanding rapidly
the lab needs a process or method for
consistent and reproducible variant
interpretation
following the published guidelines from
amp and acmg
the lab needs to be able to provide
disease-specific interpretation of
microsatellite instability and tumor
mutational burden
the lab needs clinical scientists to
perform all these activities and needs
to scale the interpretation
across multiple indications and it needs
to do all of these things quickly in
order to meet a clinically relevant
turnaround time
let's look more closely at why clinical
interpretation is so important
over the last 20 years the number of
different treatment options for patients
has grown exponentially
however only a small percentage of cases
qualifies for an fda-approved therapy
based on a biomarker
looking at one hundred thousand cases
that n of one has reported on over the
last eight years
in sixteen percent of cases an fda
approved therapy
targeted therapy is the most applicable
option
this number may even be an overestimate
in most types of cancer as non-small
cell lung cancer has a higher
has a higher than average percentage of
cases within approved targeted therapy
and this 25 20 to 25 is going to
increase even further with the recent
approval of the kraft g12c targeted
therapy
in 21 of cases there are no targeted
therapies that were appropriate for a
patient
but in the center of the curve 63
percent of
cases could qualify for a clinical trial
or off-label use of the therapy
these are the cases with the most
critical need for disease-specific
clinical interpretation
because identification of the variant
alone is not sufficient to support a
clinical decision
the physician needs to know whether that
specific variant is likely to predict
sensitivity to a therapy
what is the evidence that the variant is
actionable what is the evidence to
support the use of the therapy in that
disease type
and what clinical trials are available
that the patient could access
with the advent of comprehensive cancer
panels the number of variants to assess
is even larger than it has been in the
past
to summarize cancer genomics and
interpretation plays a critical role
in precision medicine for oncology next
generation sequencing helps to identify
the molecular
alterations that occur in a tumor an
interpretation of the sequencing results
helps to separate likely drivers from
passenger mutations
analysis of the potential driver
mutations helps physicians to match the
alterations to therapies that can target
those changes
supported by disease-specific evidence
that supports the therapy selection
kaijen's procedure precision insights
can help with the analysis required
to identify evidence-based therapies
based on identified alterations
so what is precision insights
qci precision insights is a professional
clinical interpretation service complex
complements
the user interface in qci interpret
and kyogen's other bioinformatics
solutions
qci precision insights provides human
analysis
and expert interpretation helping to
expedite
report preparation for small and large
panels
in both common cancers and rare cancer
types
precision incites triages and summarizes
content for lab director review
to assist in report writing identifying
the key pieces of evidence from the
literature
and preparing written summaries for
review precision insights
is powered by the cryogen group that was
formerly known as nf1
so who is nf1 nf1 has been in business
for nearly 13 years and we have grown
and evolved with the field of precision
medicine
we were founded in 2008 and began
working directly with physicians and
their patients
to help them to identify the most
appropriate molecular tests for their
tumors
get the test done and then explain the
results what is the role or function of
each mutation identified
and what is the impact of that mutation
in the patient's specific cancer type
through the process of working with
individual patients
nf1 established a large knowledge base
of biomarkers
genes and variants in the context of
different cancer types
linked with drugs that had emerging or
established evidence that they could
target those biomarkers in 2012 we began
working with large hospital systems and
commercial laboratories
taking in the results of patient
molecular tests and providing reports
by 2016 we had partnered with with over
30 clinical laboratories
to provide clinical interpretation
establishing ourselves as a leading
clinical interpretation business
and in 2019 we joined kiojin
bringing together nf1 somatic clinical
interpretation expertise
with kaijan's bioinformatic
computational and curation expertise
at this point nf1 has generated reports
for over 250 000 patient cases
covering over 200 000 unique variants
across
a thousand genes and over a thousand
subtypes of cancer
these numbers are out of date as soon as
i say them
as our knowledge base continues to grow
and expand each day
in 2020 nf1 now qci precision insights
expanded to offer our service to europe
with coverage of eu-specific drug
approvals guidelines
and clinical trials
so why do our partners like nf1 our
reports are prepared by an experienced
team of phd scientists supported by a
team of practicing oncologists
and we rely on people process and
technology
we have a sophisticated knowledge base
with proprietary curation tools that
help our scientists to curate the
literature
efficiently and accurately utilizing a
method of knowledge engineering that
facilitates efficient and accurate
report generation
our process both curation and software
development is controlled by a quality
management system
ensuring high quality and
reproducibility
our product is highly scalable because
of both our knowledge engineering and
the economies of scale
derived from working with many clients
we are able to return
reports quickly and expedite the sign
out process for our clients
who can simply review and sign out their
reports
we integrate securely and seamlessly
seamlessly with our clients using either
sftp
or web services and can integrate with
any bioinformatics solution
the precision insights interpretation is
powered by the precision insights
knowledge base which has been assembled
over 10 years of manual expert clinical
interpretation
the data in the knowledge base is
de-identified our clients are not
required to submit any protected health
information
the knowledge base includes information
on all kinds of biomarkers including
snvs indels fusions cnvs
as well as support for microsatellite
instability or msi
and tumor mutational burden tmb
the knowledge base includes guidelines
clinical trials and drug label
information
for both the u.s and eu with expansion
capability for any drug approval agency
the knowledge base also supports variant
gene and disease level interpretation as
well as multi-variant analysis
to dive a little bit more deeply into
how all this is done
qci precision insights employs a team of
full-time
phd scientists who are trained to our
curation process
all scientists undergo rigorous training
to the precision insights manual
and curation criteria including defined
practices for analysis
and interpretation of scientific studies
scientists are trained to evaluate
criteria including study size
overall experimental design validity and
accuracy of methods
results and conclusions all clinical
content is reviewed by a member of n of
one's team of practicing oncologists
who work with the team on a part-time
basis
the work is managed through proprietary
workflow software
and all practices including curation and
software development
are governed by a quality management
system as i mentioned earlier
the knowledge base is updated on a daily
basis actually a minute to minute basis
with new evidence from the literature
new drug approvals and guideline updates
are generally updated within a business
day of the information
becoming publicly available all the
information included
in precision insights reports is
reviewed on at least an annual basis
some information is reviewed more
frequently depending on the volume of
the literature in that particular
field clinical trials
are sourced primarily from
clinicaltrials.gov and from the who
clinical trial database
trials are updated on a nightly basis
from clinicaltrials.gov
and on a periodic basis from the who and
other sources
so what do these reports look like at
this point we'd like to walk through a
full case
to show you the content provided by
precision insights
this is an example case of a 51 year old
woman with aml
the reports shown here are very detailed
and information rich
showing in pdf format the most detailed
information that precision insights
provides
most of our clients receive this
information in xml format
via api giving them the flexibility
to discipli to display as much or as
little of the supporting information
as they prefer the laboratories still
have the supporting information
that can be supplied as an appendix or
included in a portal
or used for reference to answer
questions about the underlying data
for today's purposes we will walk
through the most detailed version of her
report
the reports are structured based on the
guidelines for reporting of somatic
variants
in cancer described in lee at all 2017
and the amp asco cap publication
the variants are organized in tiers as
described by liadol
where tier 1 represents variants of
strong clinical significance
tier 2 variants of potential clinical
significance
tier three variants of unknown clinical
significance
and tier four benign variants in this
case there are two tier one mutations
flit 3 has level a or tier 1 evidence
supporting two
fda approved drugs midastorin and
gilteritnib
both flit3 and npm1 are also associated
with level a prognostic significance
for mutations that are associated with
drug sensitivity
the summary section of the report
includes the gene
the variant therapies approved to target
this alteration in this indication
therapy is approved in other indications
with loe in parentheses
and the and whether or not trials are
available as well as whether
the specific variant is associated with
resistance to any therapies
levels of evidence are identified for
drugs associated with variance and
indicated in parentheses as i've
as i've shown as well as prognostic
and diagnostic significance
predominantly in hematologic disorders
clinical guidelines from nccn esmo who
and eln are included where they are
relevant
in this case there are eln guidelines
associated with both flit 3 internal
tandem duplication
and the npm1 alteration as well as a
bcor alteration
interactions between the variants are
shown in heme disorders
co-occurring variants can have
differential effects on prognosis
and the interaction is described on a
report level
in the summary section of the report but
is also reflected in the content on the
individual variants
in this case the co-occurrence of flit 3
and npm-1 results in a different
prognostic significance
than the occurrence of either variant
alone this information is summarized in
the interaction summary
including references for the evidence
cited
behind the front page detailed biomarker
information is included
text is written by phd scientists based
on curated literature
describing the impact of each alteration
on molecular function
disease-specific biological and clinical
relevance
and clinical evidence from the
literature so at this point we'd
like to walk through the content
included for one variant
in this case there is an activating flit
3 mutation
and internal tandem duplication so the
biomarker results summary
shown at the top indicates the take-home
message for the
for the information about this variant
what kind of mutation is it
what does it do to the gene what effects
does that have biologically and are
there any drugs available to target it
or does it have any
significant or important prognostic or
diagnostic significance
every sentence is supported by a
literature i'm sorry
a literature reference that's
immediately
referenceable by the pm pmid
in this case flit 3 itd is shown to be
an activating mutation
midastorin and gelteritnib are approved
by the fda for
flit 3 positive aml and other flit 3
inhibitors are in clinical development
each subsequent section gets more and
more detailed
the biological relevance section the
first portion
describes the molecular function of the
variant what does it do
and what is the evidence in this case
split 3 internal tandem duplication
has been shown to lead to activation of
multiple signaling pathways it results
in ligand independent dimerization and
activation
the section below describes the
incidence of the g
of the gene in this disease type this
data is derived from
cosmic and the tcga via the cbio portal
but also curated from the literature to
to ensure that there are no biases from
the cosmic or
c bio data
the next section is called clinical
relevance and this section provides
information
for both cancer in general and this
disease specifically
and if there is very specific
information about this variant it can be
included here as well
the first section roland disease
describes the
the role that this gene plays in cancer
and in this case split 3 is an oncogene
it's associated with the transformation
of myeloid cells
the next section um
describes the the next sections describe
the effect on drug sensitivity drug
resistance
and prognosis and this section includes
the multivariant analysis
so flit 3 is associated with poor
prognosis in normal karyotype aml
but in combination with npm1 has an
intermediate prognosis
and you can see that in this in the
prognostic significance section
the the annotation has been specifically
modified to include reference
to the concurrent npm1 mutation that's
been reported in this case
affecting the prognosis
for this patient with both mutations
the effect on drug sensitivity section
discusses sensitivity to tyrosine kinase
inhibitors including the approval
of midastorin and gilteritinib by the
fda for aml
the clinical evidence section gets into
incredibly deep detail
and this section is providing summaries
of specific data from clinical trials
supporting the summary information that
came earlier
it is specific to aml the disease for
this patient
and organized by the phase of the
clinical trial from which the data is
derived
in any case the highest level data for
each any given drug is provided
so for example we don't show phase one
data for a drug for which we are
presenting phase two data
we only show preclinical data if it's
very specific for the disease or the
variant
or for a new or novel therapy that has
already advanced into clinical trials
this in for each piece of information
shown on this page
describes an individual clinical trial
and result
the reports also show a list of sample
therapies
including the name the brand name if the
drug has been approved
the level of evidence targeting this
specific alteration in this disease
the target or rationale for use and the
highest level of clinical development in
any disease type
so for example
guiltyritenib and midastorn have both
been fda approved for flit 3 positive
aml
other drugs including seraphinib have
been
advanced through phase 3 in in aml
but have been fda approved in other
diseases such as
hepatocellular carcinoma and thyroid
carcinoma
the clinical trials are also displayed
in the report
these trials come primarily from
clinical trials into wh
clinicaltrials.gov and the w.h.o as
mentioned earlier
but also from a few private sources
the trials are matched based on a single
biomarker or
based on multiple biomarkers and can be
prioritized by institution
as you can see here two lists of five
trials each are provided for each
biomarker
both filtered for age gender disease and
molecular eligibility
and then subjected to different
prioritization rules
the first is filtered by clinical
specificity
or prioritized by clinical specificity
which includes the specificity for the
disease for the particular variant or
the type of variant within a gene
the other list the geographic
specificity
list shows trials that are closest to
the patient location
at the top and the patient location can
be communicated either
as the state that the patient resides in
or the zip code of the physician
so now that you've seen the content
available through precision insights
i'd like to pass to linda who will
highlight the importance of the disease
specificity
of this information
thanks cheryl so
cancers are most often classified based
on two factors
the organ of origin or the primary site
of the tumor
and the histology of the tumor the
histology refers to the type of cell
that composes the cancer
for example adenocarcinoma squamous cell
carcinoma
neuroendocrine carcinoma sarcoma etc
the specific classification of cancer is
important because different cancer types
may respond differently to the same
therapies
also cancers that originate in the same
organ can be very different cancers
taking ovarian cancer as an example here
most ovarian cancers are epithelial but
there are ovarian cancers that originate
in quarter stromal cells or in germ
cells
these tumors tend to have different
drivers and different response rates
than epithelial tumors
even epithelial tumors can be divided
into specific subtypes
such as serous endometrioid clear cell
and mucinous
and serous carcinoma can be high grade
or low grade
the specificity of the diagnosis that is
submitted to kyogen is directly related
to the specificity
specificity of the information that is
returned in a report
a case submitted with a diagnosis of
lung adenocarcinoma
will return information specific to lung
adenocarcinoma
however for a case submitted with the
diagnosis of a more general
lung cancer the case could be small cell
or non-small cell carcinoma or it could
be
a lung carcinoid for example even within
non-small cell
lung carcinoma these cases could be
adenocarcinoma squamous cell
or large cell lung carcinoma in the case
of a general diagnosis like lung cancer
the system will return more and less
specific information to cover all
possibilities of the diagnosis
to show a few more examples in the left
column we have general disease terms
including sarcoma and myeloid neoplasm
these general terms encompass many
diverse cancer types
sarcomas can be soft tissue or bony and
many such as ewing sarcoma
have very specific pathomonic diagnostic
driver mutations
the diagnostic levels of evidence will
be very specific to the diagnosis
for example an ews r1
fly 1 fusion has level a diagnostic
evidence for ewing sarcoma
but not for other sarcoma types myeloid
neoplasm encompasses a wide variety of
specific diagnoses
including aml mds and mpn as well as
specific subtypes within these diagnoses
the prognostic significance of a variant
will vary based on the specific
diagnosis
the more specific the submitted
diagnosis the more accurate
and specific the level of evidence and
pure classification of the variant
in some situations a general diagnosis
is appropriate
there are times that an oncologist or
pathologist is unable to determine a
specific diagnosis
for example a metastasis may be detected
without identification of the original
primary tumor
pathology results may be unavailable or
inconclusive
a case may be so urgent that the
interpretation is required in advance of
a specific diagnosis
in some cases the molecular results may
be needed to confirm
or refine a diagnosis finally in some
cases
a set of symptoms may be submitted to
the lab without a confirmed diagnosis at
all
in the event that a specific diagnosis
cannot be obtained the case may be
submitted with a more general term
however there are trade-offs therapies
that are approved
in a very specific disease could be
listed as approved in another indication
on the report
the levels of evidence for the general
disease particularly for prognostic and
diagnostic evidence
may be lower than for the specific
disease since the significance of a
biomarker is often tied to the specific
diagnosis
the guidelines and trials presented may
be less specific
and the trials presented will likely be
different
in general the report overall is likely
to be longer to cover more possibilities
and will contain more information about
general and related diseases
cheryl showed you a few reports that had
quite a bit of
extensive information so you can imagine
that for a general disease we like to
include
different disease types that fall under
that heading so
you can see how the contents would could
be quite lengthy for a general disease
type
let's look at a few examples
so this is a comparison of a case with a
run x1 and an asxl1 mutation with the
submitted diagnosis
of acute myeloid leukemia or myeloid
neoplasm
compared with myeloid neoplasm the first
thing you'll notice
is that the myeloid neoplasm report has
a lot more text
which i just referred to the yellow
highlights
indicate text that describes guidelines
in mds and mpn
other types of myeloid diseases in the
event
the diagnosis is unclear the mds and mpn
information could be relevant for the
patient once a diagnosis has been
confirmed
for the aml report in contrast only the
guidelines specifically related to aml
are presented
you'll also notice that the levels of
evidence are different
asx01 and run x1 both have level a
prognostic significance in aml
and run x1 is also a level a diagnostic
marker in aml
however the levels of evidence in
myeloid neoplasm
are indicated as level c because these
markers are less significant in other
types of myeloid malignancies
and these markers are not specifically
diagnostic of one specific malignancy
the level of evidence is dependent on a
specific disease
in a second example we consider a case
with a met exon 14 skipping mutation
with the diagnosis of either non-small
cell lung carcinoma
or cancer not otherwise specified
the tier classification of the met
variant is tier 1a
and non-small cell 1 carcinoma where
there are two
fda-approved drugs tapotnib and
catmatinib
that are specifically approved for this
alteration and non-small cell lung
cancer
however for the more general
classification of cancer not otherwise
specified
the met exon 14 skipping mutation is a
tier 2c
variant the drugs are only on label if
the diagnosis is non-small cell lung
cancer
while rare and other cancer types met
exon 14 skipping mutations have been
reported in other cancer types
and the targeted therapies would be
considered off-label in this context
additionally the nccn guidelines are
disease-specific as well
so they are included for the non-small
cell lung cancer diagnosis
but not for the general cancer diagnosis
in the third example we consider a case
where the disease subtype can make a
difference in the presentation of the
report
breast cancer is a disease with
molecular subtypes based on hormone
receptor and her2 status
that is typically determined at the time
of diagnosis
the submission of the hormone receptor
and her2 status as a part of the
diagnosis can affect the specificity of
the report
in this comparison we look at a case
with an herb b2 mutation l755s
and a cdkn2a mutation
for a breast cancer case that is defined
as er positive
and her2-positive the interpretation can
be tailored to that specific subtype
for example neratinib is approved for
her2-positive breast cancer
so it appears in the approved in this
indication column
the level of evidence is c 0.2 as
neratinib is being tested in clinical
trials to target l55755s
but it is not specifically approved in
the context of this mutation
the cdk46 inhibitors such as palpacyclip
and ribocycline
appear in the other indications column
because they are approved in the context
of er positive her2 minus breast cancer
the guidelines associated with
her2-positive breast cancer are
presented
in a statement explaining the potential
resistance impact of
the l-755s to
to lepatnib is included as well
for the more general breast cancer case
it is assumed to be
her2 minus and er positive as this is
the most common breast cancer subtype
as a result neratinib appears in the
other indication column
and the cdk46 inhibitors are listed as
approved in this indication
in this example no guidelines are
presented
so in summary precision insights offers
a reliable and rapid system to provide
disease-specific
and actionable clinical interpretation
the diagram
on this slide shows the workflow the
customer performs the molecular
diagnostic test and submits them in xml
format
along with as specific as possible a
disease or a
diagnosis to the kaiajin integration
server
the server pings the knowledge base to
retrieve the variant and
disease-specific information
which triggers on-demand curation when
contracted and necessary
and assembles the report which is
transferred back to the customer
the whole process is platform agnostic
and secure and the xml report allows the
customer
maximum flexibility to design their own
report
precision insight customers save time
and receive reliable results
one of our customers discusses the
reliability of the results
in the first quote and they're trusting
kaiogen for thorough and thoughtful
analysis
as well as availability to discuss the
science in the event of any questions
another customer has found that the
reports to be reliable and consistent
allowing them to save 85 to 90 percent
of the time they had been spending on
case preparation
in conclusion we've told you today about
the key components
of qci precision insights and the
importance of disease specificity
for accurate interpretation precision
insights provides expert curated
variant and disease-specific
interpretation saving time
and providing up-to-date reliable and
consistent information
with that we thank you for your
attention and we'd be happy to take any
questions
thank you dr elkin and dr call for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
what happens if we can't decide between
two diagnoses
sure i i can take this one this is linda
if you're unable to decide which
diagnosis code might be the most
appropriate you can send an email to our
support team
and we will help you choose the correct
code
as we mentioned earlier we do offer some
more general
high level codes for cases where the
precise diagnosis is unknown
for example in the case of a myeloid
disorder you know sometimes the
specific diagnosis is unknown early on
you could submit a case with a code for
myeloid neoplasm
and in that case we would return
information for the most common
disorders such as aml
mds and mpn
great thank you dr call our next
question is there a specific
list of diagnoses that we select from
when submitting a case to precision
insights
and as a follow-up question to that what
happens if we have a case with a
diagnosis that is
not on the precision precision insights
list
sure i can take that one as well um we
we do provide an
updated list of snomed light codes um
monthly to our clients um so you would
have a list
from which to choose when you were
submitting a case to us
um and for the follow-up um if if you
don't see
a diagnosis code on the list you would
reach out to our support team
and we will find and provide the most
appropriate code
based on the information that you give
and then
we would map that within our system in
time for you to submit your case
and then that would be included on the
updated list the next month
as an addition to our system
thank you so much dr call if a drug is
approved in a different disease
would we see it on the report
so i can take that question um yes you
would see it
um but as i showed you the um
the the diseases in the summary section
are shown as either approved in this
disease or approved in this indication
or we do also show
uh drugs that are approved in other
indications and
the each of them is shown with a level
of evidence so you can understand
if it's a level c point one that the
drug is approved
for that specific biomarker in a
different disease
versus a c point two or a level d where
there
it's a criteria for a clinical trial or
there's preclinical evidence for the use
of that drug
but yes we do include drugs that are
both approved on indication and
authentication thank you dr elkin
can you select clinical trials and qci
excuse me qci precision insights based
on the patient's location
and the second part is where do the
trials come from and how often is that
information updated
i can go ahead and take that one um the
patient location can be indicated
by either patient state or physician zip
code
and that information would be submitted
with the case
via the xml and trials
we find our trials primarily on
clinicaltrials.gov
and the who sites and we can also bring
in trials from other databases
and private sources as well as far as
updating um the clinicaltrials.gov
trials are updated on a nightly basis
in our system and the w80 trials are
updated on a regular basis but
less frequent than nightly
thank you dr call and i want to remind
our audience you know we are getting
some
amazing questions coming in any
questions that we don't have time for
today
will be answered via the contact
information that you provided at the
time of registration so please feel free
to keep these questions coming in
moving on to our next one what kind of
variants
can qci precision insights process and
interpret
and what data files can be uploaded
i can take that question so mo qci
precision insights can interpret
basically any kind of molecular result
that you can submit
um we can take any kind of ngs variance
so
single nucleotide variance small indels
structural variants fusions
rearrangements
copy number variants we can also take
cytogenetic variants and
fish we'll at ihc we'll work with our
clients to
ensure that we're using a consistent
controlled vocabulary so that we're
certain that for variants that aren't
described by
hgvs that we are
in agreement on the nomenclature for the
communication
of those variants in terms of what kinds
of data files can be uploaded
we work with our clients to define an
xml input so we work with you to take
your vcf or your
your your data file and submit it to us
in a standardized xml input
so that with allowing us to be able to
take not only
dna sequencing results but also the as i
mentioned the cytogenetic or fish or ihc
results as well
in addition to the diagnosis of the
patient
and the demographic information the age
and
gender that would also be used to
to filter the clinical trials
thank you dr elkin our next question
how long does it take for the
professional interpretation
service to provide me with inter
interpretive
comments
i can go ahead and take this one um we
we do have a fully automated service
that returns reports within minutes
which will contract for certain panels
and we also have an on-demand curation
service where turnaround time varies
based on the panel
and the disease the longest contracted
turnaround time would be up to three
business days
but some reports would still be returned
within minutes
and on average our turnaround time for
the curation service
is about a half a day on average
overall thank you dr call
so we have time for a few more questions
how are the oncologists involved in the
process
validating the clinical evidence in the
interpretation
summaries so
we have a fantastic team of oncologists
that have been working with us for a
very long time
um and over the years we've um made that
process more and more
um streamlined so um
we have they the oncologists review each
of the individual annotations
that refer to clinical evidence or um
any kind of clinical information
um and also answer any additional
questions
that our curators have our scientists
have in the process of their research
so they are working with us on a daily
basis we
um we have an automated system to alert
them when
um there are annotations ready for their
review
and we also reach out to them ad hoc to
get their clinical input
on the information that we're providing
thank you dr elkin and it looks like
we've got time for one more question
is it possible to configure the final
report
so yes our report outputs
are can be available either by xml or by
pdf
the pdf is a standardized pdf
um that you would be able to attach to
your report
um as an as an appendix or an edition
um and we're able to do things like
change the logo
and but not there's not a lot of
configuration available with that
particular pdf
however we also provide the information
by xml
and in the xml version
you would be able to parse that
information in whatever way
you wanted to do so that
you know you can use whatever pieces of
information from the xml
and display them in a way that that you
can customize yourself to
to you know preserve a brand or
or make your reports unique kaijen does
also have report services that can help
with
with reporting if if necessary
thank you again dr elkin and dr kaul for
your time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank labberts and our
sponsor kayajin
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speakers via the contact information
that you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labyrints will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time thank you for joining us
bye-bye everyone